KIMBERLY GUILFOYLE,
JUAN WILLIAMS, JESSE WATTERS AND
GREG GUTFELD.
IT'S 5:00 IN NEW YORK CITY AND
THIS IS SPEETHIRTY.
IMMIGRATION FRONT AND CENTER IN
DOWN.
A FEDERAL JUDGE TEMPORARILY
BLOCKING PRESIDENT TRUMP'S
EFFORTS TO END THE DACA PROGRAM.
THE WHITE HOUSE BECAUSE THE
INJUNCTION OUTRAGEOUS.
MR. TRUMP HAD WORDS EARLIER
TODAY.
>> WE WANT TO SEE SOMETHING
HAPPEN WITH DACA.
IT'S BEEN SPOKEN OUT FOR YEARS.
OUR COUNTRY WAS SUCH A MESS, NO
ONE KNOWS WHAT THE NUMBERS ARE.
WE WILL KNOW WHAT THE NUMBERS
ARE.
ABOVE ALL ELSE, ANY BILL WE
PASSED MUST IMPROVE JOBS, WAGES,
AND SECURITY FOR AMERICAN
CITIZENS.
THE PEOPLE WHO ELECTED US, ALL
THEM.
>> Dana: THE BLOCK CAME AFTER
CRISIS FOR 800,000 YOUNG PEOPLE.
EVERY SINGLE DAY THAT GOES BY,
YOUNG PEOPLE ARE LOSING STATUS,
WHICH MEANS THEY ARE SUBJECT TO
BEING DEPORTED BY I.C.E.
IT MEANS SOME OF THEM CANNOT
LEGALLY SHOW UP FOR WORK
ANYMORE.
THE WHOLE NOTION THAT WE PUT
THAT OFF IS WRONG.
>> Dana: SOME CONSERVATIVES
DON'T WANT TO SEE THE PRESIDENT
COMPROMISE ON IMMIGRATION.
>> ANYONE IN WASHINGTON STARTS
TALKING ABOUT AMNESTY,
UNITED STATES ILLEGALLY, THERE
IS A FRESH SURGE ACROSS OUR
BORDER.
>> THAT IS NO "ART OF THE DEAL."
HARD-LINER ON IMMIGRATION IN THE
ROOM.
WE CAN CALL THE SLOWEST DAY IN
THE TRUMP PRESIDENCY.
>> Dana: KIMBERLY, THIS
JUDGE'S DECISION, WHEN
PRESIDENT OBAMA MADE THE DEAL
WITH DREAMERS, IT WAS BY
EXECUTIVE ORDER AND TODAY WE SEE
IS THAT THE WHITE HOUSE IS
HAVING TO GRAPPLE WITH -- THE
COURTS NEVER SAID OBAMA'S ORDER
COULD NOT STAND BUT THEY ARE
SAYING PRESIDENT TRUMP'S CANNOT
STAND BUT IT'S ALSO BY EXECUTIVE
>> Kimberly: A BIT OF
DISPARITY AND HYPOCRISY.
>> Dana: TRYING TO LEAD THE
WITNESS.
>> Greg: I REST MY CASE.
>> Kimberly: THE THING IS
THERE'S ALWAYS A DOUBLE STANDARD
AS IT RELATES TO
PRESIDENT TRUMP.
IT'S LIKE THE NINTH CIRCUIT, THE
TRAVEL BAN, EVERYTHING GETS SENT
BACK TO THEM.
THERE SHOULDN'T BE A DIFFERENCE.
IT IS THE SAME MECHANISM BY
PRESIDENT OBAMA DID.
BECAUSE THEY OBJECT TO HIM DOING
IT, THEY ARE GOING TO FIND FAULT
WITH IT WHERE THEY WOULDN'T
OTHERWISE WITH PRESIDENT OBAMA.
I THINK THIS IS WHAT HE FINDS TO
BE PARTICULARLY FRUSTRATING AND
AS IT RELATES TO THE
CONSERVATIVES ON THE RIGHT,
GREG, YESTERDAY YOU WERE SAYING
ANN COULTER WOULD BE NONE TOO
PLEASED BY THIS ORDER.
>> Dana: WHAT DO YOU THINK OF
ALL THIS >> Greg: ESTHER
YESTERDAY --
AFTER YESTERDAY I AM SELF
IDENTIFYING AS A DREAMER.
WHY CAN'T I?
GROUP PROBABLY SINCE THE BEATLE
BEATLES.
I AM SORRY TO SAY TO JOHN
LENNON, JESUS IS MORE POPULAR
THAN JESUS.
THIS IS ABOUT BEING OUT OF
POWER.
TRUMP IS MOVING IN THEIR
DIRECTION.
THE ANGRIER ANN COULTER GETS,
THE MORE ELIZABETH WARREN SHOULD
BE HAPPY.
HE IS MOVING AWAY.
HE WANTS A DEAL AT A DEAL MEANS
HE IS WILLING TO DO A LOT MORE.
>> Kimberly: IT'S BECAUSE IT'S
HIM.
>> Greg: AND NO MATTER WHAT HE
DOES.
IT'S NOT HIS DEMEANOR, NOT THIS
DEMENTIA THEY TALK ABOUT.
IT'S BECAUSE THEY ARE NOT IN
POWER AND THEY DON'T LIKE HIM.
>> Dana: ON THE POLITICS SIDE
OF THINGS, THE CONSERVATIVES
EXPRESSING DISAPPOINTMENT, THEY
ARE UPSET ABOUT THE POLICY.
I THINK IT DOES DEAL WITH HOW
YOU DEFINE AMNESTY.
>> Jesse: IF YOU GIVE THE
A LOT OF PEOPLE.
I WOULD HAVE A PROBLEM WITH IT.
THAT MIGHT NOT BE PART OF THE
DEAL.
A LOT OF PEOPLE SAY 800,000
DREAMERS VOTING.
IF YOU LOOK AT THE BIG DEAL,
BORDER HAWKS ARE GETTING A LOT
DONE.
NOT ONLY ARE THEY GETTING
FUNDING FOR THE BORDER WALL.
THEY ARE GETTING MORE BORDER
AGENTS, IMMIGRATION JUDGES.
GETTING RID OF CHAIN MIGRATION
YOUR COUSIN, YOUR UNCLE, COME ON
IN.
THE LOTTERY SYSTEM, THEY ARE
GETTING RID OF THAT.
WHEN YOU DON'T HAVE A PARTY, YOU
DON'T HAVE PEOPLE COMING IN
THEY ARE MOVING TOWARD A
MERIT-BASED SYSTEM.
I THINK CONSERVATIVES,
ESPECIALLY BORDER HAWKS, IF THEY
WOULD TAKE ANY OF THESE ITEMS
AND PUT THEM INTO A GROUP AND
SAY WE'VE GOT TO LEGALIZE SOME
DREAMERS, YOU DON'T PUNISH THE
SUN FOR THE SINS OF THE FATHER,
THEY WOULD TAKE IT.
IN ANY DEAL, YOU'RE KNOCKING TO
BE HAPPY 100% BUT IT'S PRETTY
GOOD.
SOME ON THE FAR LEFT ARE ASKING
FOR TOO MUCH FROM DEMOCRATS AND
THEY SHOULD BE SUPPORTIVE OF THE
DEAL THEY ARE GOING TO GET.
>> Juan: THEY ARE SAYING
UNITED WE DREAM HAVE BEEN
ATTACKING DEMOCRATS.
THEY SAID YOU PROMISED YOU WERE
GOING TO STAND BY US.
DIRECTING THEIR IR AT THE
DEMOCRATS FOR NOT BEING MORE
VOCIFEROUS, MORE AGGRESSIVE
TAKING ON THE PRESIDENT.
YOU HEARD THEM SAY IT WAS THE
CONVERSATION ABOUT THE DREAMERS
FORCED OUT TECHNICALLY.
WHEN YOU STOP AND THINK ABOUT
IT, IT'S TRUE.
NOW THE PROBLEM HERE I THINK IS
TWOFOLD.
I WANT TO STAND UP FOR HER.
THE COURT DIDN'T SPEAK TO
WHETHER OR NOT THERE WAS ANY
LEGITIMACY TO AN EXECUTIVE
ORDER.
THIS WAS ABOUT DONALD TRUMP'S
TWEETS.
YOUNG PEOPLE.
THEY HAVE JOBS.
THEY ARE IN THE MILITARY.
WHY WOULD WE KICK THEM OUT?
THE JUDGE IN SAN FRANCISCO SAYS
THAT SOUNDS LIKE THE CHIEF
EXECUTIVE WHOSE JOB IT IS TO
MAKE THE JUDGMENT, THINK IT'S IN
THE PUBLIC INTEREST.
AS WE SAY NOW, WE THINK THE
PUBLIC INTEREST IS SERVED BY
WHAT THE PRESIDENT SAID.
MR. PRESIDENT, YOU GET YOUR
WISH.
DON'T KICK OUT THE DREAMERS.
>> Dana: PERHAPS THIS FORCES
CONGRESS TO NOT JUST WORRY ABOUT
THE PRESIDENTS DEADLINE BUT NOW
THERE'S A COURT SITUATION.
YOUR REPUBLICANS AND DEMOCRATS
WHO CAME TOGETHER YESTERDAY, AND
>> Kimberly: I THINK THAT'S
WHAT WE ARE TALKING ABOUT HERE,
YESTERDAY AS WELL.
NEGOTIATING AND BEING ABLE TO
TRY TO COME TOGETHER, THIS IS
SOMETHING PRESIDENT TRUMP EXCELS
AT ANY WANTS TO PUT A LITTLE BIT
OF PRESSURE, A LITTLE BIT OF A
FOOT ON THE PANEL, GIVE IT SOME
GAS, SO HE CAN MAKE SURE
DEMOCRATS ARE GOING TO TRY TO
ENGAGE.
LIKE YOU SAID, DANA, PEOPLE ON
THE RIGHT GETTING UPSET BECAUSE
IT'S TOO MUCH OF A GIVEAWAY.
YOU HAVE VOCAL OPPONENTS ON THE
SIDE, LIKE WE SOW.
AND THEN YOU HAVE SOME DEMOCRATS
WHO STILL DON'T SEEM TO BE HAPPY
ENOUGH WITH ALLOWANCES THAT HE'S
MAKING THAT IN FACT OUR DIRECT
ACCORDANCE WITH WHAT THEY WERE
SUPPORTING.
IF HE'S GOING TO GET THE DEAL
DONE AND BE OBJECTIVE -- THE
OBJECTIVE IS TO GET A DEAL DONE.
IMMIGRATION OR ANYTHING ELSE,
DACA, DREAMERS, TAXES,
HEALTH CARE.
HE WANTS TO GET A TON.
WHAT CAN HE GIVE AND PRESSURE?
HOW CAN HE PERSUADE PEOPLE TO
EVERYBODY IS UNHAPPY ABOUT A
DEAL.
THAT MEANS THEY DIDN'T GET
EVERYTHING.
IF NOBODY GETS EVERYTHING THEY
WANT, THAT MEANS SOMEBODY GAVE
AND YOU HAVE THE DEMOCRATS.
THAT'S WHAT HAPPENS IN A
NEGOTIATION COMING AND ADIL.
I DON'T GO FOR DEALS FOR THE
SAKE OF DEALS.
HE WANTED A TAX DEAL.
WE WEREN'T PLEASED WITH IT.
IT FELT LIKE HE WANTED A DEAL.
ACOLYTES IN THE WHITE HOUSE
CONTINUE TO FLOCK THE DEAL.
WE SAW PEOPLE CROSSING THE
BORDER NOW, IT SET OUT 45 YEAR
LOW.
THEN YOU DON'T NEED BILLIONS FOR
AN ACTUAL WALL.
>> Greg: THE PREMISE IS BASED
THOSE ARE THE ONES THAT HAVE
GOTTEN CAUGHT.
I'M SURE ANOTHER 1,000 ARE
SLIPPING BY.
THE WALL THAT YOU SAID YESTERDAY
WAS TOO EXPENSIVE.
MEDICARE COME EACH YEAR THEY
SPEND ABOUT 600 BILLION.
IT >> Juan: YOU ARE COMPARING
IN THE BUCKET.
>> Juan: TAKING CARE OF PEOPLE
WHO ARE AMERICAN CITIZENS WHO
NEED MEDICAL CARE IS THE
EQUIVALENT OF A WALL?
YOU KNOW WHAT, WE REPORT.
I THINK PEOPLE KNOW THEY NEED
DEMOCRATS, AND THIS GOES BACK TO
DISCUSSION.
DEMOCRATS WANT THE DREAMERS TO
STAY.
THEY ARE WILLING TO NEGOTIATE IN
TERMS OF ADDED BOOTS ON THE
GROUND AT THE BORDER, MORE
SECURITY IN TERMS OF DRONES,
AIRCRAFT, ELECTRONIC
SURVEILLANCE.
TRUMP COMES OUT AND SAYS NO, NO,
NO.
WE'VE GOT TO HAVE THE WALL.
>> Jesse: BECAUSE HE'S A
NEGOTIATOR.
I GUARANTEE YOU'RE GOING TO HAVE
WALL FUNDING AND THE DREAMERS
PROTECTED.
>> Dana: WHAT WILL END UP
HAPPENING IS HE WILL CALL IT
TO STAY ONLY BECAME AN ARGUMENT
NEGOTIATE OVER.
WHICH IS NOW ALLOWING HIM TO
MAKE PROGRESS ON THE BORDER
CONTROL, NO MATTER WHAT YOU CALL
IT.
>> Dana: I THINK IT WAS A
STEVE BANNON MOVE.
>> Greg: IT MIGHT'VE BEEN.
HERE IS SOMETHING THAT'S
NOW YOU HAVE A NEGOTIATION.
>> Juan: I THINK THAT'S RIGHT
BUT I THINK THAT'S WHY THE
DEMOCRATS THAT HE CREATED AN
NOW WE ARE UP AGAINST IT.
OTHERS SAYING WAIT A MINUTE.
THIS IS NOT WHAT YOU PROMISED IN
THE CAMPAIGN.
>> Dana: HE HE SAID HE WILL T